Democrats in the media didn't waste much
time to blame climate change for the
horrific wildfire that happened in Maui
if you look at it I mean everything from
the fire the tragic fire in Hawaii to
Texas which had something like 75 days
in a row over 95 I mean it's completely
really amazing what has happened with
climate change stop these disasters from
getting even worse we have to cut the
carbon pollution that's driving the
climate crisis we very much need to
acknowledge that climate change is upon
us there are host states by the way Jake
where you can't even the use the words
climate change because they still have a
hit in the sand attitude the inflation
reduction act provided some 300 billion
dollars to combat climate change and and
to move us away from continuing Reliance
on fossil fuels but now that narrative
just got confronted by reality Maui
officials are publicly blaming Hawaii's
largest electric utility company for the
deadly wildfires filing a lawsuit that
claims it was their intentional and
malicious mismanagement of power lines
that allow the Flames to spark Fox News
digital reaching out to five Democratic
lawmakers who pushed the theory that
man-made global warming was to blame but
only hearing back from one all right
judge they have a lawsuit and
that's going to be about the power
company to deal with but immediately
it's almost as if any issue can if you
don't want to deal with accountability
you just say climate change yeah well I
think I've said this before in the
winter it's all about covid in the
summer it's all about climate change
okay and we just need to put more money
into it I heard today the president's
going to ask for more money for covet I
mean uh so here we go again but look if
if What Maisie
the hirono of What Maisie senator hirono
says is true 300 billion dollars to
fight climate change how come this kind
of thing is happening all right the
inflation reduction Act was all about a
giveaway to the green energy companies
in the end uh it's not about global
warming and it's not about climate
change it's about negligence pure and
simple it's about ineptitude it's about
an area that didn't keep up with what
was going on because they were trying to
get to the green energy next step and so
they were too busy working on green
energy they ignored the obligation of
the current situation they didn't fill
the water reservoir okay they didn't
turn off the power lines when they got a
warning that there would be high winds
coming and they fail to follow protocol
to uh to to shut down the live power
lines and so what we've got now is the
power lines are igniting dry grass and
Bush and people died as a result of it
and they didn't even send off these
Sirens they said the guy said he was
worried that people would run toward the
fires if they turned the sirens off
right you know it's it's about an excuse
we live in a world that's all about
excuses that is is blocked in terms of
ideology it's all tribalism you're on
this side you're on this side facts are
irrelevant and they had all of this
money Brian that they were well they
knew about the Wildfire threat they had
money that was they could use to deal
with the Wildfire threat but instead
they used it on green energy projects
and they didn't do anything to try to
mitigate a problem like this one right
uh and the guy that said came out and
said we didn't want people we don't want
to put the sirens out because we want
people running Inland I'm pretty sure
adults know not to run into a fire right
all right number two he resigned the
next day right nice uh they call it
non-native grass they said that the
grass is highly flammable they said you
got to get it out you got to thin it out
you got to get rid of it they just left
it and the minute these power lines with
the downslope of the wind along with the
hurricane it was The Perfect Storm it
burned everything but they said this
grass is the thing that ignited the
whole thing so having said that if you
want to talk about climate change and
you want to be effective pick your spots
when you say it all the time people turn
off and is there anybody less
interesting to talk to talk climate
change than Anthony fauci was Terry
Pratt show not available
I was stunned to see him there I mean my
idea of a personal disaster would be if
I found myself trapped on a desert
island for the rest of my natural life
with Dr Anthony fauci the worst and
Karine Jean-Pierre both of them braying
at me morning noon and night uh with
their views on life um look I think the
climate change is real I believe that I
believe that man-made contributions are
a significant factor in what is going on
in the overheating of the planet but I
also think that there are two other
massive problems in Mr B hysteria and
hypocrisy and what those two things do a
little bit like they did with covid
actually is they discourage large sways
of the public from trusting people they
should be trusting we've got to have
trust in public or visuals you don't get
it by blaming stuff like this on the
wrong thing you actually increase
distrust in public officials Jesse
Waters tonight on prime time we have the
researcher who authored the initial
report saying that man-made climate
change was creating more ferocious and
more deadly hurricanes she's now come
out and said she got her facts wrong and
there is no connection and now nobody in
the scientific Community wants to talk
to her they're just running with the
junk science and sadly this has been
seized upon by these politicians and
when you blame it on climate change
during a deadly tragedy it just divides
everybody and everybody goes to their
corners and they start fighting with
each other when you should be trying to
get to the bottom of this investigation
that proves as you and you said this was
negligent homicide on on a mass
murderous scale by Hawaii electric no
comment that is the biggest story that
nobody's talking about the president
United States did nothing didn't comment
for three days and was asked about it
actually said no he doesn't want an
investigation into this yeah why is that
over 100 people dead and we still have
you know what that's complicated and
there's no easy answer
that's what you have to remember that's
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else